من المحتمل ألا تلاحظ الجولات
اختلاف البوصة ونصف الآن في
برج بيزا المائل ، ولكن بالنسبة
للمهندسين الذين عملوا
بجد لمحاولة إنقاذ
برج بيزا المائل من السقوط ، فإن هذا أمر
رائع حقًا منذ حوالي 20 عامًا.
وضعوا خطة هي بالفعل
حقًا رائدة في إزالة
بعض الأوساخ الموجودة أسفل الجانب الذي
كان البرج مائلًا إليه وربطوا
أوزانًا ثقيلة جدًا في ذلك الوقت ، قام البرج
بتصحيح نفسه حوالي 18 بوصة في الوقت
الحالي يميل البرج حوالي 13 قدمًا عن
العمودي و  هذا ما اتجهت إليه
منذ حوالي 200 عام ، تجدر الإشارة إلى
أن البرج بدأ في
الميل حتى عندما كانوا يبنونه
في الطابق الثالث ، وفي الطابق الثامن قرر
المهندسون في 11 مائة
أن عليهم عمل بعض
الأعمدة  لفترة أطول من أجل محاولة
تقويم البرج ، لذا حتى لو كان
برج بيزا المائل مجهودًا
لتقويمه أكثر ، فسيظل
منحنيًا